Euron Greyjoy: Circling the Jade Sea is the
dream of every merchant.
On the other side is the Golden Empire of
Yi Ti.
Even its ruins dwarf every city in Westeros
and its princes are said to live in houses
of solid gold and feast on meat powdered with
pearls and jade.
Foolish talk!
If it were true, I would have visited long
ago.
But a bold merchant will risk two years for
one voyage to fatten his holds with spices,
gems, and silks so that he never wants for
anything again.
To be fair, many never do, because my ship,
Silence, finds them on their return.
Their merchant dreams look so pitiful poured
on my decks.
Not enough for any lifetime but their own.
JaqenH'ghar: A young man walks beside a girl
across a flowered field.
Spring has come, and this girl is his life.
He prays.
A child climbs a tree to watch the sunset
over the fields.
Summer is ending, and the harvest is life
for his village.
He prays.
A hunter tracks a boar through the woods.
Winter is coming, and this boar is life for
his family.
He prays.
But to whom do they pray?
The world has as many answers as there are
men to answer, but walk far enough, climb
high enough, hunt long enough, and a man shall
find only one.
One god with many faces.
In the Far East, He is the Lion of Night,
who fathered the world's first emperor on
the Maiden-Made-of-Light, and whose wrath
nearly ended the world.
In the House of Black and White, however,
He is all of them, and none of them.
He is the Many-Faced God, and wherever a man
turns, there He is.
Men come from every corner of the world to
know Him, to beg His favor, and seek His gift.
For themselves, if their life has grown too
hard, or for others who are making it so.
It is all the same to the Many-Faced-God.
"Valardohaeris," all men must serve Him, beggars
and kings.
"Valarmorghulis," all men must die, good and
evil.
Men worship as they will, but at the end of
every road stands the Many-Faced God, waiting.
XaroXhoanDaxos:Our city, however, would be
quite a prize for any empire.
Qarth straddles two worlds: a greedy and curious
west and a rich and mysterious east.
The marvels of Yi Ti and Asshai pass through
our markets and share berths with the riches
of the Free Cities and Westeros.
Our ports have fulfilled many a trader's dreams,
almost as many as they have broken.
Samwell Tarly: The Maesters don't believe
in prophecy, with good reason.
The Children of the Forest supposedly could
see into the future, yet were surprised by
the First Men who nearly ended their race
and the Long Night, which nearly ended us
all.
Even the wisest Maesters, however, have no
answers for the Red Priests who prophesy about
the return of the Long Night.
For thousands of years, they've kept watch
for the return of The Prince Who Was Promised,
who will be born amid salt and smoke to drive
off the darkness once again.
Prince of what realm and promised by whom
and to whom?
The prophecy doesn't say, but at the very
least, it confirmed that not even Essos escaped
the Long Night.
I imagine the cataclysm must have confused
the East.
Unlike Westeros, they wouldn't have known
of the Night King or the White Walkers or
the war waged by the First Men and the Children
of the Forest.
They would have just seen a terrible winter
descend and linger far too long until spring
magically returned to the world.
Yet somehow, maybe from passing merchants,
maybe in their fires, the Red Priests saw
the truth.